why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so the X-Men first appeared in September
of 1963 with X-Men issue number one and
in the novel The Son of origins of
Marvel Comics Stan Lee gave us an
explanation as to how it was the X-Men
came into existence as to how it was
that he and Jack Kirby had thought up
the idea and what Stanley told us was
that up until the point of the X-Men's
introduction that they had conceived of
a multitude of characters and teams of
course we had the Fantastic 4 we had the
Incredible Hulk but the problem here was
that they had gained their abilities due
to external factors The Incredible Hulk
had been exposed to the gamma bomb the
Fantastic 4 had been exposed to cosmic
rays and Stanley and Jack Kirby
rationalized that you can only have so
many instances where characters are
exposed to something externally that
gives them Powers before people begin to
become bored of it and so what he
thought of here what he came up with was
this idea of people of individuals who
were simply just born with their powers
and for him this was a spectacular idea
and the reason why is because when you
had an element where something external
had happened to a character that gave
them Powers their powers had to relate
to whatever that external issue was
whatever that external thing happened to
be they also couldn't have powers that
were just absolutely nuts because again
if Spider-Man was bitten by a
radioactive spider he then couldn't turn
around and became become somebody who
was able to manipulate reality he would
most likely have the powers of a spider
and so with characters who were born
with abilities there was no limit to
what could be done there was no limit to
what kind of powers they could have and
so Stan Lee immediately jumped at this
idea and pitched it to Jack Kirby and
the more that Jack Kirby and Stan Lee
had gone over this concept the more the
concept began to take on a life of its
own to the point that they realized that
this could really become something
massively successful and so what they
did is they went to the head of Marvel
Comics at the time Martin Goodman and
they threw the idea to Martin Goodman to
see what it was that he would think
about this but Martin Goodman really had
a more Antiquated way of looking at
comic books but also looking at comic
book readers to Martin Goodman the
largest majority of comic book readers
were children and children were not
going to be able to grasp this concept
of more adult-oriented stories they were
not going to be able to grasp this
concept of what a mutant was but Stan
Stanley disagreed St Stan Lee looked at
the X-Men and said that it was Marvel's
chance to tap into the older reader to
tap into those individuals who were
adults in reading comics those who are
close to adulthood and reading comics
that are looking for more than these
escapades involving superheroes the
other half of this equation is that the
Fantastic 4 was again the most popular
team that Marvel had and the reason for
this was because they had looked at real
world events and they had paralleled
real world events in the Fantastic 4
comics and so what Martin Goodman did is
eventually acquiesced but there were
constringent or I'm sorry constraints
that were put on the X-Men when it went
to publication and this a lot of people
considered to be the reason why the
initial X-Men stories had failed of
course we had seen characters introduced
and teams introduced like Magneto and
the Brotherhood of evil mutants but the
stories for the most part were childish
the stories for the most part were never
really anything that adults or near
adults could relate to and so with issue
number 66 the X-Men had more or less
began to flounder but what we'll see is
that while the stories were reprinted up
until issue number 93 that in May of
1975 something would happen with the
X-Men a person would be introduced to
write the stories of the X-Men that
would look beyond their powers that
would look beyond the villains they
faced and would focus on the individuals
themselves would focus on what their
ideas were what their desires were what
it was that made them who they were and
that this would ultimately reshape the
X-Men not just in the immediate but for
the future existence of the X-Men in
Marvel
[Music]
Comics so by 1975 Chris Claremont was a
fledgling writer for Marvel Comics he
was looking to uh move beyond the role
of being a uh I guess a writer that
wasn't taken that seriously and wanted
to be viewed as someone who could be a
major player within the realm of Marvel
Comics and so ly wine who of course at
the time was the uh editor for Marvel
had looked at uh Chris Claremont as
somebody who could potentially be a
serious writer but the issue here is
that Lyn wine couldn't simply just hand
over a major publication he couldn't
just give Chris Claremont the uh
Fantastic 4 or Iron Man what he had to
do is he had to segue in he had to uh
have him do like most every other writer
had done at the time and start from the
bottom and work his way up and so while
he was on credited Chris Claremont had
uh under the tutelage I guess of Lind
wine brought to us in May of
1975 giant size X-Men issue number one
and what this did is it allowed Marvel
to segue from the old X-Men team into
the new X-Men team and as we start this
story for the most part what this is
going to do is just give us an
explanation of what it is that Xavier's
doing of course we start off in Germany
with the introduction of Nightcrawler
and we see that for the most most part
Nightcrawler is apparently escaping some
sort of angry mob and that this mob is
pursuing him most likely due to his uh
physical appearance and this is
confirmed as we read along and learn
that they view him as some kind of
monster as some kind of devil and
because of that their intention here is
to kill him is to uh to burn him from
here we switch to uh wolver rain and
what we get with wolver rain is this
idea that while he had pre previously
worked for the federal government that
the offer of working for the X-Men has
been extended to him by professor
Charles Xavier now initially the
government doesn't want to let wolverin
go due to the fact that he is been an
invaluable asset given his experiences
in Espionage as well as his overall uh
experiences worldwide in terms of
operating for the government but
wolverin looks at this as his
opportunity to move away from working
for the federal government and so he
immediately accepts the offer of Charles
Xavier at this point we transitioned to
Banshee and of course in Tennessee
Banshee is attending the grand old opery
and Charles Xavier visits him now
Banshee had previously appeared in the
original X-Men comics and so for Charles
Xavier this was the idea of revisiting
somebody he already knew as opposed to
pitching an idea to somebody that he
doesn't know and what he tells Banshee
is that he's in need of a new team that
he needs someone that can undertake the
role of helping to lead some of the uh
new members of the X-Men that he's
currently recruiting and so Banshee for
the most part appears to be on board
from here we switch to a Roman row to
storm in Africa and storm using her
powers demonstrating her abilities for
those who are worshiping her as the uh
goddess of Africa is approached by
Charles Xavier and Charles Xavier says
that he is in need again of a team that
he's in need of people who will help him
fight the good fight in terms of uh
leading individuals that will fight
against those that will oppress the uh
mutant population but what he also says
to Aurora Monroe is that she has
incredible power that she has incredible
abilities that her position as being
viewed as a goddess among the people of
Africa is something that can translate
into the experience of uh being both
wise and intelligent in terms of her
role in the X-Men at this point we
switch to Japan and we see that uh that
Charles Xavier is meeting with Sunfire
and Charles Xavier again like the other
characters that we've seen before is
approaching Sunfire with the hopes that
he will join the X-Men that he will join
this team and uh what onfire says is
that initially he's a little skeptical
that uh he doesn't really feel as though
he owes Charles Xavier anything and
there doesn't really seem to be a reason
for him to join the X-Men but the more
that he thinks about it the more he
realizes that maybe he owes something to
himself that while the Western World
isn't necessarily something that he
trusts that perhaps it's his opportunity
to give Japan a better view in the eyes
of the world and so Sunfire chooses to
join the team of the X-Men at this point
we switch over to uh Russia and in
Russia or I guess the USSR at this point
we meet with Colossus and Colossus as
he's doing farm work in a really
interesting situation here which of
course is something that would be
touched back on again in the House of M
is again approached by Charles Xavier
after seeing him manifest his ability to
take on a organic metal form and stop a
tractor from running over a child and
what Xavier says is that he wants
Colossus to join him that Colossus is a
very powerful foe but Colossus also has
a good heart that he is a good person
and that because of this he can use his
goodness along with his powers for the
benefit of the world as a whole and so
Colossus chooses to join the X-Men he
chooses to join professor Charles Xavier
and to leave his family behind at this
point we switch to the Apache nation and
this is a really interesting situation
here because what we get is the idea of
um of I guess the Native American
element of America joining the X-Men as
a whole joining the X-Men as uh as a
part of their major team and again this
is Marvel touching on the idea of having
a multicultural team of including a
multitude of various people into the
idea of the uh Marvel Comics to maintain
this concept of a more Progressive
attitude and so what we see as is that
as Charles Xavier continues to approach
John proudstar that he asks him again to
join his team that he asks him to join
the X-Men and again this is simply just
Charles Xavier trying to enlist the aid
of others as long as they can carry out
the role that he wants to have the X-Men
follow that he wants to have the X-Men
use in terms of protecting humanity and
initially again John proud store a John
proud star like Sunfire isn't
necessarily on board at first he doesn't
really want to go with Charles Xavier he
doesn't like this idea but what he says
is that as time progresses he wants to
make a better impact on the world but he
also is baited a little bit he's taunted
a little bit by Charles Xavier and
Charles Xavier says that uh perhaps all
the Apaches are weak that perhaps
they're frightened that they're selfish
that they have no real measure of honor
and so John proudstar agrees he says
that he's not going to be considered a
coward that he is just as strong as the
next person that he's just as great as
the next individual and so he chooses to
join the X-Men alongside Charles
Xavier from here for the most part we
see this team completely formed we see
this uh X-Men team brought to us as
individuals are uh putting on their gear
and they're assembling themselves and
what would become their most common
X-Men outfits but what we also get is
the I guess the return of Scott Summers
and this is really really big here and
the reason reason why is because as we
know Scott Summers was part of the
original X-Men team but when the
original X-Men team went away and became
xfactor that everyone of the original
all the original members of the X-Men
team had joined xfactor with the
exception of Cyclops and what Charles
Xavier says is that Cyclops is going to
be the leader of the X-Men team that
he's going to be the leader of this uh
faction of mutants and that he will
undertake the role of making sure that
they are trained making sure that they
are effective as a team that they are
coh iive as a team and for the most part
this is going to pick up with uh the
allnew all different X-Men issue number
one or X-Men issue number 94 depending
on on how it is that you uh uh count
your X-Men Comics but this is going to
begin this uh this new introduction of
the X-Men characters this is going to
begin this new uh revolution of X-Men
characters and again with Chris
Claremont taking over the role of the
X-Men is going to give us this
opportunity to see just what happens
when the X-Men begin to to grow and they
begin to evolve and we begin to look
beyond their powers and we begin to
focus on them as
[Music]
individuals so with X-Men issue number
94 or the first issue of all new all
different X-Men what we saw was Chris
Claremont being held up or being led as
the main writer for the series and under
Chris Claremont the X-Men exploded in a
way that nobody had ever expected the
series grew to such a scale that it
became the best-selling comic book that
Marvel had going at the time and the
reason why was because under Chris
Claremont we saw an introduction of a
Litany of new characters we saw the
introduction of Rogue psylock uh Shadow
Cat of Jean Gray in the as the Phoenix
force in issues number 107 and 108 we
saw the introduction of uh of siren
Rachel Summers meline prior Jubilee we
saw all these characters coming to
fruition within the pages of the X-Men
series but what we also saw was Chris
Claremont launching spin-offs Chris
Claremont introduced the New Mutants in
1982 he introduced Excalibur we also saw
what many consider to be one of the
greatest crossovers in terms of the
X-Men related titles and the mutant
Massacre and we also saw things like the
extinction agenda with Chris Claremont
he had revolutionized the X-Men he had
made the X-Men something spectacular
and this is why the X-Men were so
successful prior to the Chris Claremont
run of the X-Men all we really saw in
the comics was maybe some RNR time when
they weren't training and going against
foes like Magneto under Chris Claremont
we saw stories where the X-Men would be
out performing their holiday shopping
and then suddenly be attacked by
Sentinels in addition to this what we
saw is what many consider to be the uh
creation of one of the greatest stories
Ever Told in the graphic novel God loves
man kills now God loves man kills was
created in 1982 and this was actually uh
created both with Chris Claremont and
Brent Anderson John burn actually didn't
have anything to do with this but what
this introduced to us is what I consider
to be one of the greatest villains of
the X-Men a villain named William
Striker and the reason why was because
William Striker was a an Evangelical he
was a radical Fundamentalist he was a
man whose perspectives of mutant kind
could not be assuaged he was a villain
that couldn't be changed he couldn't be
reasoned with he simply just wanted to
see the elimination of all mutants
because he believed it was his mission
from God and of course this is the the
comic book that X-Men 2 is based off of
under Chris Claremont again we saw the
X-Men grow we saw them expand we saw
some of the most memorable characters to
have ever been in existence in the X-Men
Comics coming out of the Chris Claremont
era but what we saw in
1991 was that Chris Claremont eventually
left and he stopped writing for X-Men
and when he did we saw what many
consider to be the downward decline of
the X-Men
[Music]
Comics so by 1989 John burn had
previously departed from the X-Men
series and so Marvel had substituted
John burn with a series of artists to
assist Chris Claremont in keeping the
X-Men uh series popular and while some
individuals came and went we eventually
saw that Marvel had paired uh Chris
Claremont and Jim Lee together now while
Chris Claremont and Jim Lee didn't
necessarily have the uh creative element
that Chris Claremont and John burn had
they were still able to create some
great characters and great stories
nonetheless but the problem here is that
Marvel was looking at the mutant
Massacre crossover event and the success
that came came with it and so what they
wanted to do is they wanted to create
more crossover events they wanted to
keep them as a regular thing and so the
problem that Chris Claremont and Jim Lee
faced was that it was very difficult to
maintain this very indepth and this very
intimate concept involving these
characters while also building them up
towards these crossover events now that
doesn't mean that all the crossover
events were bad not at all in fact Age
of Apocalypse which was in 1995 is
considered by many to be one of the
greatest crossover events part of the uh
the X-Men franchise series but the issue
here is that by 1991 Chris Claremont had
left the X-Men and in 1992 Jim Lee had
done the same and so Marvel began to
sort of panic here they began to freak
out a little bit the reason why is
because while they were maintaining
these crossover events while we were
seeing things like the Executioner song
crossover in the end we had seen this
almost total loss of the uh up close and
this in-depth character sort of an
analysis that we had seen with the Chris
Claremont run of the X-Men and so this
is how the X-Men continued they began to
sort of putter along they began to uh
kind of continue along and began to more
or less just be a series of comics that
was based on stories and not necessarily
focused on the characters but by 2005
Marvel had looked at the X-Men franchise
they had looked at the entire series
overall and it come to the conclusion
that for the most part there were just
too many characters to keep up with
there were some characters who were
appearing and then were never seen or
heard from again because the continuity
was just too massive and too convoluted
and so what Marvel did is they launched
a story called The House of M and the
House of M of course was the story where
the scar witch had warped reality but
what it did is it allowed Marvel to
consolidate the mutant population by
having 98% of mutants lose their powers
and so where previously we had had
thousands upon thousands of characters
we now had about two or 300 that
actually had powers and of those two or
300 we only really had to focus on a
handful in order for the stories to
remain uh interesting in order for the
stories to maintain their Intrigue in
addition we had seen that Marvel had
toyed with the idea of reintroducing
characters with powers and so what they
had done is they had launched a story
called The Messiah complex and the
Messiah complex introduced Hope Summers
and her relationship with cable but what
it also did is it it was more or less
Marvel telling us that that of the 200
some OD mutants that are currently in
existence that others will begin to
regain their powers While others will
not have any powers at all and so the
mutant population began to grow and it
began to expand but at a very slow rate
and so with Messiah complex we saw the
Messiah war and after the Messiah War we
saw the 12 lights and again this was
simply just marvel bringing back the
element of some characters gaining
Powers it was their chance to introduce
new characters to introduce new abil
abilities based on the idea that while
other characters had lost their powers
that the powers couldn't have simply
just disappeared that they had to have
gone somewhere Now by 2012 Marvel was
also introducing a Marvel wide event
called Marvel now and what this did is
it allowed Marvel to go back and to
consolidate all these backstories of all
these characters and all these events
across the Marvel board but what it also
did is it gave him the chance to look at
individuals within the realm of the
X-Men franchise and to ask the question
who should get their own comics and so
that's when we saw stories like Magneto
we saw characters like Magneto getting
their own stories with Magneto issue
number one and of course things
continued along this path up until the
current day where we of course have the
allnew X-Men which is where X-Men from
the past in an alternate Dimension have
been brought to the main Earth one Earth
616 Dimension and then sent to the
Ultimate Universe now what Marvel will
intend to do with the X-Men in the
future is something we're not really
sure of all we know is that over the
course of the X-Men's history we saw
them introduced as a group of teenagers
then we saw them uh I guess elevated to
a more in-depth and a more adult
Orient
[Music]